guten Abend hallo noch mal zu einer
zweiten Runde ZDF heute live heute Abend
kam die Meldung rein das ist neue
Hinweise gibt zur Explosion der Nord
Stream Pipeline letztes Jahr im
September noch mal zur Erinnerung
Explosionen hatten am 26 September in
den Wirtschaftszonen Schwedens und
Dänemarks in der Ostsee mehrere Lex in
die Pipelines Nord Stream 1 und Nord
Stream 2 gerissen die eben für den
Transport von russischen Gas nach
Deutschland gebaut worden waren die
Pipelines waren zum Zeitpunkt der
Explosion nicht in Betrieb sind hielten
aber Gas und nach Angaben Schweden
steckt Sabotage hinter dem Vorfall weil
eben auch sprengstoffreste nachgewiesen
werden konnten darüber wollen wir jetzt
reden wie gesagt gibt es neue Hinweise
ihr könnt uns Fragen und Kommentare
schicken am besten in die Chats posten
oder eben an die E-Mail-Adresse schicken
die jetzt eingeblendet wird und damit
schalten wir direkt zu unserer
hauptstadtkorrespondentin chakunterla
benaji nach Berlin
was kannst du uns erzählen was sind das
für neue Hinweise um die es da geht ja
das waren die Kollegen von der ARD und
von der Zeit die die aktuellen
Ermittlungsergebnisse ausgegraben haben
und die sind tatsächlich schon
erstaunlich detailliert in mancher
Hinsicht die Kollegen die Ermittler
haben wohl schon herausgefunden mit
welchem Boot der Anschlag auf die
Pipeline verübt worden sein soll es soll
sich um eine Yacht handeln die von einer
Firma angemietet worden ist die Ukraine
gehört die Firma hat ihren Sitz in Polen
und involviert gewesen sein sollen sechs
Besatzungsmitglieder die den Anschlag
durchgeführt haben ein Kapitän zwei
Taucher zwei tauch Assistenten und eine
Ärztin ähm laut Informationen von ARD
und Zeit die das ähm die den Sprengstoff
transportiert haben soll und zum Ort
gebracht haben soll und losgegangen ist
Struktur anscheinend von Deutschland aus
das Boot soll in Rostock schon am 6
September gestartet sein dann mit
Zwischenhalt auf dem Darß und in
Dänemark zum Tatort gefahren sein wo
sich dann in der Nacht zum 26 September
die Explosionen ereignet haben und das
Interessante ist dass man eben diese
detaillierten Kenntnisse hat dass man
auch zwei Reisepässe gefunden hat die
allerdings professionell gefälscht sein
sollen und damit steht noch die Frage im
Raum wer verbirgt sich hinter diesen
gefälschten Pässen denn tatsächlich gibt
es die Verbindung zu der Firma die das
Boot angemietet hat und die Ukraine
gehört es ist allerdings nicht klar ob
es sich tatsächlich bei der Besatzung
auch um Ukraine gehandelt hat und dann
schließt sich natürlich an dich als
Hauptstadt die Frage an wie die
Bundesregierung auf diese neuen
Erkenntnisse reagiert
ja da gab es heute große Zurückhaltung
es gibt eine Erklärung von der
Bundesregierung ein Regierungssprecher
hat gesagt dass die Bundesregierung
diese neuen Berichte erst einmal zur
Kenntnis nimmt viel weiter wurde das
nicht kommentiert
man hat darauf verwiesen dass die
Ermittlungen beim Generalbundesanwalt
liegen und er auch die Hoheit über das
Verfahren hat da kann sich die
Bundesregierung in der Tat nicht
einmischen der
Generalbundesanwalt der ermittle schon
seit Anfang Oktober und Deutschland habe
über den Stand des Verfahrens gemeinsam
mit Schweden und Dänemark die auch in
die Ermittlungen involviert sind vor
wenigen Tagen noch die Vereinten
Nationen informiert und da heißt es
wörtlich darüber dass die Untersuchungen
laufen und ist noch kein Ergebnis gäbe
man sieht man ist hier sehr vorsichtig
mit diesen vorläufigen
Ermittlungsergebnissen weil man eben
abwarten muss in welche Richtung das
ganze dann am Ende geht
okay also im Moment halten sich alle
noch sehr bedeckt vielen Dank für den
Moment
und einen schönen Abend noch tschüss
ja und weil die New York Times ihre
Recherchen dazu heute Nachmittag
rausgebracht hat schalten wir jetzt
weiter nach Washington zu unserem
Korrespondenten el MRT Wissen hallo Elma
hallo nach Deutschland
welche Informationen du hast es eben
mitbekommen bei shakuntaler hast du
darüber hinaus und wie waren die
offiziellen Reaktionen in den USA
ja die New York Times berichtet eben im
Grunde genommen entlang der Linie die
chakunterlauf hohen beschrieben hat ganz
offenbar hatten amerikanische
Geheimdienste und
us-regierungsmitarbeiter Zugang zu eben
diesen ermittlungs- und und
Beweismaterialien und auf dieser Basis
kommen sie eben zu dem Schluss das mit
hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit eine
pro-ukrainische Gruppe hinter diesen
Anschlägen stecken soll so heißt es hier
tatsächlich so zitiert ist die New York
Times es gibt keine genauen Erkenntnisse
wer die Einzelpersonen sind über das
hinaus was wir vorhin gehört haben außer
dass die US-Regierung davon ausgeht es
waren weder amerikanische Staatsbürger
noch britische Staatsbürger in
irgendeiner Form beteiligt sondern eher
das ist die Annahme hier in Washington
waren es Ukrainer oder Russen die diese
Tat ausgeführt haben sollen so
jedenfalls ist die Leser hier es wurde
natürlich in den Briefings hier beim
Weißen Haus beim staty-partment auch
beim Nationalen Sicherheitsrat dann
nachgefragt und wir bekamen im Grunde
genommen eine vereinheitlichte Antwort
die da eben heißt dass die Ermittlungen
tatsächlich ja von Deutschland Dänemark
und Schweden durchgeführt werden und
dass man hier nicht kommentiere welche
Ergebnisse es möglicherweise gibt weil
die Ermittlungen auch nicht
abgeschlossen sein aber die Sprecherin
des Weißen Hauses wurde vorhin auch
danach gefragt ob möglicherweise der
deutsche Bundeskanzler am vergangenen
Freitag als er im Opel Office bei
Präsident beiden war diese
Ermittlungsergebnisse quasi mitgebracht
hat um sie auch zu diskutieren mit dem
amerikanischen Präsidenten die
Sprecherin des Weißen Hauses sagt sie
werde keine Details über dieses Gespräch
veröffentlichen über das was letzte
Woche schon dazu gesagt wurde nämlich
eigentlich wenig bis nichts aber es
drängt sich ein bisschen der Fahrer
Verdacht auf dass man sich natürlich
schon abgestimmt hat zwischen der
deutschen Regierung und auch der
amerikanischen Regierung wie man darauf
reagiert denn das ist ja ein
hochsensibles Thema wenn sich beweisen
ließe dass die Ukraine hinter diesen
Anschlägen steckt dann könnte das
Einfluss eben
auf die Freundschaft die verbünden das
Bündnis im Grunde genommen haben aber
und auch das ist wichtig so berichtet
die New York Times die amerikanischen
geheimdienst- und Regierungskreise sehen
momentan keinerlei Belege dafür dass es
eine direkte oder indirekte Verbindung
zur ukrainischen Regierung zum
ukrainischen Militär oder irgendwelchen
Stellen in der Ukraine gibt die hinter
diesen Anschlägen als Drahtzieher
stecken könnten also durchaus brisante
Informationen wie groß ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es sich auch um
eine falls Fleck Aktion handeln könnte
also dass da absichtlich eine falsche
Fährte in die Ukraine gelegt wurde
auch darauf wird hier hingewiesen dass
das absolut vorstellbar wäre und dass
das noch völlig offen ist es gibt
Hinweise darauf dass das relativ
professionell durchgeführt worden ist
nicht nur wegen des Sprengstoffs der
benutzt wurde sondern auch wegen der
gefälschten Papiere und das ganz
offenbar erfahrene Taucher dabei gewesen
sein müssen die möglicherweise auch
irgendwann war irgendwann einmal im
Militär ausgebildet worden sind aber es
lässt eben nach wie vor offen wer
dahinter stecken könnte und es wird hier
darauf verwiesen dass wir in den
vergangenen Monaten ja mehrfach Aktionen
erlebt haben von denen man nicht genau
weiß wer dahinter steckt damit sind
nicht z.B der Angriff auf die krimbrücke
gemeint da hat man sehr deutliche
Querverbindungen nach Kiew zu
ukrainischen Regierung gefunden als die
Brücke dort in die Luft gesprengt wurde
mit einer Lastwagen Bombe aber damit ist
gemeint der
Bombenanschlag auf Daria du Gina die
Tochter eines russischen Nationalisten
in Moskau das war im August vergangenen
Jahres etwa fünf Wochen nur bevor dann
der Anschlag auf die Pipelines verübt
worden ist da haben die Amerikaner bis
heute nicht den Eindruck dass
ukrainische Stellen wirklich offizielle
Stellen in irgendeiner Form dahinter
stecken also es wird hier gemutmaß dass
es eine pro ukrainische Gruppe gibt
möglicherweise auch mit russischen
Staatsbürgern die gegenputin eingestellt
sind und die mit solchen Sabotageakten
ich sag mal den Kampf der Ukraine
flankieren noch mal eine Nachfrage zum
Verständnis es wurde ja sehr detailliert
beschrieben wer diese Leute waren ne
fünf Männer eine Frau eine Ärztin und so
weiter aber
wer diese Personen dahinter sind dass es
nach wie vor völlig unklar
das ist unklar man hat eben diese zwei
gefälschten Pässe gefunden man weiß wie
die Anmietung Erfolg ist eben bei einer
Firma der die Yacht gehört und diese
Firma gehört wiederum zwei Ukrainern
aber man weiß über die Personen an Bord
die dort waren eben nicht viel mehr man
weiß auch dass sie ein Lieferwagen
angemietet hatten um eben den
Sprengstoff in den Hafen in Rostock zu
bringen wo am 6 September ja dann das
Schiff abgelegt hat also deswegen sagt
man hier auch noch mal ganz klar es ist
durchaus noch offen wer letztlich hinter
diesen Anschlägen steckt aber es gibt
deutlicher Hinweise dafür dass ich sag
mal eine pro-ukrainische Gruppe
möglicherweise auch mit Russen beteiligt
dabei sind solche Sabotage auszuführen
und ähm ich sehe gerade das Reuters
jetzt meldet das ähm selenski sich zu
dem Report geäußert hat und ähm sagt er
absolut Leben nach dem Wolf in Nord
Stream attack has now Info an what
happened also die Ukraine ist da nicht
involviert und man weiß nicht was da
geschehen ist dazu vielleicht eine Frage
von Sven oder gibt es schon Reaktionen
aus Russland oder China dazu
ich habe noch keine Reaktion aus
Russland oder China dazu gehört und
gelesen bisher nur hier aus Washington
aber wir erinnern uns russland hat ja in
der Vergangenheit den USA und
Großbritannien vorgeworfen hinter diesen
Sabotageakten an der Nord Stream
Pipeline oder an den Pipelines zu
stecken das haben die USA mit
Entschiedenheit zurückgewiesen vor
einigen Wochen hat auch ein
amerikanischer ich sag mal ehemaliger
Star Journalist der jetzt eher als
Blogger mit Verschwörungstheorien
unterwegs ist eben auch diese Theorie
verbreitet dass die USA auf Befehl von
Präsident Joe Biden diese Anschläge
verübt hätte hätten das hat das Weiße
Haus ganz empört und entschieden
zurückgewiesen und vor diesem
Hintergrund ist eben nach wie vor nicht
geklärt wichtig ist dabei die Frage
natürlich wer hat einen Interesse daran
diese Nord Stream Pipeline zu zerstören
wir erinnern uns das war September
letzten Jahres da gab es eine Diskussion
in Deutschland darüber wie man über
einen möglicherweise schwierigen bekommt
und ob man nicht doch vielleicht in
irgendeiner Form russisches Gas nehmen
sollte um dies zu gewährleisten die
Amerikaner hätten andere Mittel gehabt
sagen uns jedenfalls Quellen hier in
Washington um so etwas zu unterbinden
indem sie zum Beispiel auch Sanktionen
verhängt hätten gegen jedermann der auch
nur einen Kubikzentimeter Gas aus solch
einer Pipeline dann tatsächlich nimmt
aber es wurde auch damals schon gemutmaß
dass die Ukraine ein hohes Interesse
haben könnte wir hören jetzt wo du mir
selenski der das auch empört zurück weiß
also möglicherweise handelt es sich um
eine dritte Gruppe über die wir zwar
jetzt ein paar Details wissen aber die
waren Drahtzieher dahinter eben noch
nicht kennen und traut das meldet jetzt
auch dass russische Behörden das auch
zurückweisen vielen Dank elmatte wissen
für deine Informationen nach Washington
danke schön tschüss
und wir wollen jetzt noch mit dem
Fregattenkapitän und Experten für
maritime Sicherheit bei der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik sprechen mit
Göran
danke dass Sie Zeit für uns haben was
sie da jetzt bis jetzt alles gehört
haben wie plausibel klingt das für Sie
für mich klingt das jetzt noch gar nicht
überzeugend man hat keine Fakten bisher
in den Berichten die wir heute vernommen
haben geliefert viel mehr hat man neue
Spekulationen über die Urheberschaft
aufgemacht sie haben das selber gerade
schon diskutiert angefangen von Prob
ukrainischen Gruppen vielleicht auch
russischen prokrainischen Gruppen bis
hin zu einer faustfleck Operation wurde
da vieles aufgeführten genannt das wurde
leider nicht mit irgendwelchen beweisen
untermauert ferner die Details die in
diesen Berichten so angeblich geliefert
wurden scheinen auch noch etwas
unlogisch zu seiner mietet in Polen ein
Boot an bewegt sich dann nach Rostock
und es mit einem Transporter wo
wahrscheinlich große Mengen Sprengstoff
drinne waren und man selbst gefälschte
Ausweise benutzt hat und dann von
Rostock was wieder weiter entfernt von
Polen ist äh eine solche Aktion zu
starten das klingt alles noch nicht so
wirklich schlüssig und es sind auch
anscheinend keine untermauerten Fakten
von daher würde ich dazu raten die
Spekulationen vielleicht erstmal noch
mal ein bisschen zur Seite zu packen und
zu warten auch in den nächsten Tagen
vielleicht von den mittelungsbehörden
dazu noch Fakten kommen
wie kann das denn überhaupt sein dass
eine solche Aktion
komplett unbemerkt bleibt also wie gut
ist diese Pipeline überwacht gewesen
selber ist gar nicht so gut überwacht
wir haben große Defizite noch in der
Überwachung von seeräumen je weiter weg
diese auch von Land liegen sowohl über
Wasser wie auch unter Wasser es gibt
mittlerweile seit den Anschlägen von
nordsingen einige Bemühungen Strukturen
zu schaffen
Fähigkeiten einzurichten und auch mit
den Betreibern solche Infrastruktur
zusammenzuarbeiten um das Lagebild zu
erhöhen nicht so trotz halte ich für
durchaus möglich dass man sich unbemerkt
in Seeraum auch bewegen kann wenn man
das möchte
durchführen kann das ist derzeit noch
möglich
denn das Viertel hat eine Frage auf
Youtube sie fragt hätte die Ukraine die
technische und logistische Möglichkeit
so eine Operation durchzuführen
die Frage scheint jetzt in diese in eine
staatliche Richtung zu gehen das heißt
Ukraine als Stadt die dann
wahrscheinlich irgendeine Spezial
Einheit eine Geheimdienst Operation
durchführt das heißt man müsste
Material verbringen Sprengstoff
verbringen oder irgendwo im Ausland
kaufen ohne dass es anderen auffällt man
müsste sich mehrere europäische Länder
reisen
ob die Ukraine diese Fähigkeiten hat
naja sie setzen wahrscheinlich auch
hinter ihren oder hinter in derzeitigen
feindlichen Bienen Spezialkräfte ein
möglich wäre das schon macht es da macht
es Sinn und was wäre die Motivation ja
ich glaube ich würde generell in dieser
Diskussion mal drei Aspekte
unterscheiden einmal brauche ich für so
eine für die Durchführung und Planung
einer solchen Operation eine
entsprechendes Fachwissen Umgang mit
Munition oder mit Sprengstoffen
Explosivstoffen Fachwissen wie ich
natürlich auch tauche auf solchen großen
Tiefen dann das wissen wie ich
entsprechende Zünder einbaue das erlange
ich nicht einfach so das ist nicht
oftmals ein jahrelange Ausbildung
insbesondere Militär wir sind nicht
wirklich viele Leute in Deutschland
bekannt die das beides zusammenbringen
weniger als eine Handvoll würde ich
sagen und die sind alle in staatlichen
Sicherheitsorgan beschäftigt das zweite
Bereich ist das Material ist dieses Brot
oder ein Brot als Transportmittel
der Sprengstoff die gefälschten Pässe
all das muss ich erstmal irgendwoher
beschaffen ohne dass es jemand
mitbekommt unter einem Deckmantel das
kostet auch alles Geld ohne dass es
jemanden auffällt und der dritte Bereich
und das ist jetzt die Frage die hier
vielleicht auch noch mit angerissen
wurde ist die Frage nach der Intention
und Motivation was würde es der Ukraine
bringen oder was bringt es der Ukraine
diese Pipeline die zu dem Zeitpunkt ja
auch gar nicht mehr also Nordsee 2 war
noch gar nicht in Betrieb eins mit den
Sanktionsmaßnahmen und der Reduzierung
der
Abhängigkeit durch russisches Erdgas
wurde auch nicht mehr
genutzt dementsprechend hätte man eine
Pipeline gesprengt symbolisch vielleicht
ähm oder einen wirklichen negativen
Effekt für Russland zu generieren und
der negativen Effekt in Deutschland war
ja vorher schon gegeben dadurch dass wir
uns generell ja mit unseren Energie oder
so fossilen Rohstoffen neu aufstellen
kommt aus anderen
Ländern aus anderen Regionen das nun
importieren müssen
von daher die Frage wem schade ich dann
mehr und wenn das irgendwann zu Tage
kommt dass es ein ukrainischer Operation
ist wie es vorhin auch schon
angesprochen wurde bei Ihnen ob ich dann
nicht selber dem Verhältnis des Westens
Europas Deutschlands zu Ukraine und auch
der derzeitigen Unterstützung für
Ukraine mehr schade das würde ich
vielleicht auch als Frage noch mal in
den Raum stellen
es gibt nur meine Frage einer schreibt
also eines sollte klar sein und zwar das
ist irgendeine Regierung war oder also
was denken sie könnte auch eine kleine
Gruppierung hinter dem Anschlag stecken
oder braucht es bei einem Anschlag
dieser Größenordnung sage ich mal schon
eher die Unterstützung einer Regierung
oder eines eines Geheimdienstes
theoretisch ist es natürlich möglich
dass eine ganz kleine Gruppe die dieses
Fachwissen alles auf sich bald so und
mitbringt die auch über die
entsprechenden Finanzen verfügt und das
vielleicht auch schon über Monate Jahre
vorher geplant hat so durchführt das ist
theoretisch vorstellbar in der Praxis
halte ich das eher für unrealistische
ich glaube schon dass hier auch gewisse
größere Organisation Strukturen mit
involviert sein müssen finanziellen
Unterstützung
weil das Fachwissen was ich hier
zusammenbringen muss
und dann stellen wir uns mal vor wie wir
heutzutage ja teilweise in stillen
Kemmler Kämmerlein selbst radikalisierte
Personen auffinden können die Anschläge
planen das ganze dann unentdeckt vor
anderen Sicherheitsorganen durchzuführen
ist heutzutage ja auch relativ schwierig
weil man ja immer irgendwo
Mobilfunknetze nutzt das Internet
E-Mails etc und da gegebenenfalls dann
auch solche Stichworte die
Explosivstoffe oder Anschläge irgendwo
mal aufpoppen und dann
Sicherheitsorgane alarmieren
und dann gibt es noch eine Nachfrage von
Manuel Schäfer er fragt ähm ob die NATO
den Ostsee Raum nicht engmaschig
überwacht
die NATO besteht ja auch nur aus ihrem
Mitgliedstaaten und die Mitgliedstaaten
im Ostseeraum haben natürlich gewisse
maritime Fähigkeiten wie sie
insbesondere ich sage mal in Zeiten wo
keine Krise ist oder kein Krieg herrscht
erstmal auf ihre eigenen trittal
Gewässer konzentrieren die Anschläge
sind nun jenseits von territorial
Gewässern durchgeführt wohnen in einem
Bereich wo man auch gar nicht davon
ausgehen eigentlich dass dort eine
größere Aktion eine eine
eintage durchgeführt wird
jetzt sind natürlich nach diesem
Anschlag alle Länder etwas mehr
alarmierten richtet jetzt Strukturen ein
Mann schafft sich Fähigkeiten an um auch
weiträumig sehr Raum zu überwachen das
wird in Zukunft möglich sein innerhalb
der NATO aber auch Deutschland auch
durch das Zusammenspiel verschiedenster
deutscher Sicherheitsorgane wird das
möglich sein
insofern war dieser Anschlag dieser
Sabotage natürlich auch so eine Art
Backofen für die NATO-Staaten und für
die Ostsee arbeiten alleine
und noch eine letzte Frage von Olaf
Schärding wie wahrscheinlich ist eine
taucheroperation wenn mehrere hundert
Kilo Sprengstoff eingesetzt wurden
ich brauche dafür schon technische
Hilfsmittel ich muss das ganze natürlich
irgendwie im Wasser ablassen können dass
er das heißt ich brauche das Material
das habe ich vorhin schon mal
angesprochen ich muss auch das Wissen
haben wie solche Mengen an Sprengstoff
verbringe grundsätzlich möglich wenn ich
eine Yacht habe die vielleicht mit auch
irgendeine aussetzt Vorrichtung versehen
ist die ich mir selber vielleicht auch
mitgebracht habe
ist das natürlich theoretisch
vorstellbar dann gibt es verschiedenste
Möglichkeiten die solche schweren
Gewichte und auch alles was ich dann zum
arbeiten brauchen natürlich in die Tiefe
bringe dann gibt es verschiedene
ballonartige Schwimmkörper von denen man
dann nach und nach Luft ablassen diese
dann quasi im Wasser absacken sowas gibt
es heutzutage das ist möglich da kann
ich auch mit zwei drei oder vier Leuten
entsprechende große schwere Arbeiten in
hoher oder ein großer Wassertiefe
durchführen aber ich muss natürlich die
Kenntnisse darüber haben das bringt
nicht jeder Taucher mit es ist in der
Regel auch eine langjährige
kostenintensiver Ausbildung die man
insbesondere bei Militärs bekommt
vielen Dank für Ihre Einschätzung danke
dass Sie so kurzfristig Zeit hatten
tschüss
ja und damit verabschieden wir uns für
heute ich fasse mal ganz zu kurz
zusammen es gibt neue Hinweise zu den
Anschlägen auf die Nord Stream Pipelines
Indizien deuten darauf hin dass eine
Pro- ukrainische Gruppe hinter der Tat
stecken könnte ZDF heute live einen
schönen Abend noch tschüss